حامله الطائرات الامريكيه تواجه صواريخ
الحوثيين وزير الامن القومي العبري يهدد
نتنياهو الامم المتحده تقدم شكوى ضد تلبيب
امام مجلس الامن الدولي الرئيس المصري
نواجه منعطفا شديد الخطوره ومعبر رفح لم
ولن يغلق كوريا الشماليه تعزز قواتها على
الحدود مع الجاره الجنوبيه والقواعد
الامريكيه تحت انظار كيم جونجون المانيا
ما بين اختيار الداخل او اوكرانيا سلاح
روسي كالصداع بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه
وموسكو تصرح اعضاء النيتو ينظرون للصراع
في اوكرانيا باعتباره استثمارا
مربحا الهدنه على حافه
الهاويه تاخرت الهدنه ل يوم واحد ما اثار
الشكوك لدى الجميع هنا هدد وزير الامن
القومي العبري اتمار بن غفير النتنياهو
بالاستقاله من الحكومه اذا لم يستانف
القتال ضد الفصائل في القطاع بعد صفقه
اطلاق سراح الاسرى والرهائن فيما قال هرتس
هاليفي رئيس اركان الجيش العبري في لقاء
جمعه بقياده الجيش داخل القطاع ان الحرب
متواصله ولن تتوقف من جانبه اعلن لبنان ان
بعثته الدائمه لدى الامم المتحده تقدمت
بشكو ضد تلبيب امام مجلس الامن الدولي
يتمها فيها بتعمد قتل الصحفيين بحسب صحيفه
الشرق الاوسط ليخرج الناطق الملثم للفصائل
ابو عبيده ويصرح ان الفصائل دمرت
335 اليه عسكريه واستهدفت عشرات الجنود
اخرها كمائن التوام والرنتيسي وبيت حانون
هنا صرح الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
ان القضيه الفلسطينيه توجه منحنى شديد
الخطوره لفرض واقع جديد بتصفيه القضيه
وتهجير الشعب والاستيلاء على الارض مضيفا
لن نقبل بالتهجير القسري للفلسطينيين ولا
تصفيه القضيه كما اعلن عن انطلاق قافله
مصريه ضخمه نحو القطاع واكد السيسي ان
معبر رفح لم يغلق ابدا ولن يغلق في وجه
المساعدات الموجهه للقطاع بينما نقلت
وكاله بلومبرج عن مسؤول في وزاره الماليه
العبريه ان بلاده ستواجه عجزا متزايدا في
الميزانيه خلال العامين المقبلين قد يصل
الى 9% من حجم ناتجها المحلي الاجمالي في
سياق التدخل الخارجي اعلنت القياده الوسطى
الامريكيه ان حامله الطائرات يو اس اس
هادن في البحر الاحمر اسقطت عددا من
المسيرات الهجوميه التي انطلقت من مناطق
يسيطر عليها الحوثيون في اليمن ولم تتعرض
السفينه وطاقمها لاي ضرر او اصابه لننتقل
الى شبه الجزيره الكوريه حيث افادت
الوكاله المركزيه للانباء في كوريا
الشماليه بان جيش البلاد يعزز القوات
المنتشره عند المنطقه العازله بين
الدولتين الكوريتين وذلك بعد تعليق الجاره
الجنوبيه للاتفاق العسكري بين الكوريتين
واضافت وزاره الدفاع ان كوريا الجنوبيه
ستتحمل كامل المسؤوليه في حال حدوث صدام
بين الشمال والجنوب تاتي هذه الاحداث بعد
ان وضعت كوريا الشماليه قمرا صناعيا في
مداره معلنه انه التقط صورا لقاعده اندرسن
الجويه ومنا اي ابر في جزيره جوام
الامريكيه وارسلها الى بيونج يانج وفق
وكاله انباء كوريا الشماليه ورطه المانيه
احفاد هتلر يضاعفون دعمهم لاوكرانيا لكن
هل لديهم القدره على الايفاء بوعودهم هنا
صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال الامريكيه تجيب
بانه جراء تجميد الانفاق الحكومي الالماني
حتى نهايه العام سيتعين على برلين
الاختيار بين الدعم المالي للشركات
الالمانيه او مساعده اوكرانيا من جهه اخرى
اكد رئيس الوزراء الهنجري فيكتور اورب ب
ان استراتيجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي فيما
يتعلق بالنزاع في اوكرانيا فشلت وروسيا لن
تهزم ولهذا يجب على الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
يبحث عن خطه بديله واكد اوربن انه على
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يكون مستعدا ليجد
نفسه بمفرده في النزاع الاوكراني لان
الولايات المتحده قد تختفي من المشهد بعد
الانتخابات فيما قال رئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي بن كاردن
ان اوكرانيا في وضع يائس وتحتاج لمساعدات
امريكيه عاجله خلاف لتل ابيب القادره على
الدفاع عن نفسها ليستجيب وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن بقوله ان اجمالي حجم
المساعده العسكريه التي وعدت مجموعه
الاتصال بتقديمها للجانب الاوكراني قد
تجاوز بالفعل 80 مليار دولار في الميدان
قال المستشار السابق في البنتاجون
الامريكي العقيد دوجلاس ماكريغور ان
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه على وشك
الانهيار بسبب ارتفاع مستوى الفرا بين
صفوف الجيش اضاف ماكريغور ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تهرب الان باعداد كبيره وهناك
العديد من القاده الذين يسلمون وحدات
صغيره كامله لانهم لا يستطيعون اجلاء
الجرحى فيما افادت صحيفه بزنس ان سير بان
المروحيه القتاليه الروسيه كا 52 تمساح
تشكل تهديدا خطيرا للقوات الاوكرانيه على
خط المواجهه واوضحت الصحيفه ان مروحيه كا
52 الروسيه اصبح كالصداع بالنسبه للقوات
الاوكرانيه خلال الهجوم المضاد الصيفي في
جنوب اوكرانيا لتعلن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
الحصيله بتكبيرات
وجريحا واسقاط مروحيه ام اي 8 و24 مسيره
اطلقتها قوات كيف على مختلف المحاور خلال
24 ساعه وبين هذا وذاك صرح السفير الروسي
لدى بكين ايجور مورولو ان اعضاء النيتو
ينظرون الصراع في اوكرانيا باعتباره
استثمارا مربحا وبالنسبه لهم تعتبر حياه
الجنود الاوكرانيين ثمنا بسيطا مقابل
اضعاف روسيا وفق
[موسيقى]
تعبيره